Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt, aber ich bin ein bisschen verletzt.
Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt, aber ich bin ein bisschen verletzt. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt, aber ich bin ein bisschen verletzt.
Sie müsste man auch herstellen. Warum willst du sie rausnehmen? Der Staat übergibt dir das Dokument praktisch. Er will natürlich auch, dass es da eine Stelle gibt, die da dann auch noch Geld verdient, bzw. die diese hoheitlichen Aufgaben übernimmt. Der Pass selber oder der Ausweis ist ja nicht nur die Signatur, sondern es ist natürlich auch ein optisches Merkmal mit Sicherheitsfeatures drauf. Also da sind inzwischen so viele Sachen, dass man das nicht auf ein Zertifikat runterbrechen kann.
Und was wir an der Stelle sehen?
Der Punkt ist, dass ich im Prinzip, könnte man einfach auch sagen, diese optischen Sicherheitsfeatures, die sind eh nicht mehr zeitgemäß, weil das würde dir sowieso nicht gefällt.
Na ja, also die Streifenpolizisten, die existiert schon, auch wenn man sie nicht mehr so häufig sieht.
Also zum Thema Fälschen, also der deutsche Reisepass ist halt immer noch das sicherste Reisendokument auf der Welt. Das heißt, die haben so viel Sachen drauf, um jetzt zu behaupten, das kann man ganz einfach fälschen. Das ist auf jeden Fall irgendwie nicht richtig.
Was man machen kann, ist es schlicht kaufen. Also das ist ja nur schon seit Längerem bekannt. Es gab halt diese ziemlich bekannte Doku der BBC, wo sie mal einen Journalisten losgeschickt haben und die hat tatsächlich aus 20 europäischen Ländern Ausweisdokumente gekauft. Das war so ein Preis zwischen 150 und 1500 Pfund. Also in Deutschland oder in Frankreich war es teurer als etwa in Slowenien oder in der Slowakei. Aber die Gefahr ist ja nicht die Fälschung des physischen Dokuments. Weil das ist halt einfach zu schwer und zu teuer. Sondern man bestichtert einfach jemanden, das ist Usus. Und nicht etwa, dass man sich hinstellt und zu Hause in seiner Fälscher Werkstatt da anfängt zu kopieren.
Mit Blaupause und Bleistift und Papier und irgendwelche Dinge zu machen. Was wir übrigens vorhin, da gab es noch einen Einwand, den wir dringend noch korrigieren müssen. Der Preis für den elektronischen Reisepass von 60 Euro, da wird natürlich nicht von der Bundesdruckerei festgestellt, festgelegt, sondern vom Ministerium. Richtig, klar. Nicht, dass die Bund das sagt. Okay, das musste nur noch kurz geklärt werden.
Ja und dieser RSA-Kartenplan ist natürlich auch aus anderen Gründen unausgereift. Dieses Zertifikat ist auf der Karte schon drauf, allerdings verwenden sie nicht unbedingt RSA, sondern sie machen da ECC zum Beispiel. Du hast das Problem, dass du gegebenenfalls nicht in der Lage bist, einen sicheren Schlüssel zu generieren. Das ist nämlich alles, wird dann von der Bundesdruckerei in ordentlich zertifizierten Umgebungen gemacht, während wenn du selber zu Hause einen Schlüssel generierst, wenn du eine Debian-Kiste hast, naja.
So den will ich auf der Karte generieren.
Ja, ansonsten, wenn du ihn auf der Karte generierst, das machen sie nämlich extra nicht bei diesem professionellen, kommerziellen System, weil sie dem Zufallzeilen-Generator auf der Karte nicht so sehr vertrauen, dass er nicht vielleicht doch irgendwann mal was falsch macht.
Jemand muss jetzt mal Hendrik stoppen, sonst sieht er nicht mehr aus.
Und selbst wenn du ihn extern generierst, selbst wenn du ihn, du kannst ihn auch selber erzeugen und dann kannst du, also ein Bekannter von mir hat sich zum Beispiel einen Schlüssel, einen RSA-Schlüssel erzeugen lassen, wo eine der beiden Primzahlen drei war. Und den dann offiziell signieren lassen. Von daher, das ist auch ein interessanter Faktor.
Warte mal, Gentlemen, kurzer Einwurf. Das führt jetzt sehr, sehr, sehr ins technische Detail. Simon, ich würde vorschlagen, wenn dich das mir noch mehr interessiert mit der Generierung dieser Schlüssel auf der Karte, dann einfach eine Mail schreiben an Chaosradio, die CDU und Henrik und du, ihr könnt euch dann stundenlange Mails hin- und herschicken.
Und er meint es so stundenlang.
Nee, weil ohne Quatsch, ich bin jetzt ausgestiegen. Ich verstehe kein Wort mehr. Ja, also wenn ihr beiden Hardware-Nerds könntet das vielleicht dann irgendwie untereinander klären oder weitere Fragen dann dazu machen, weil wir wollen eigentlich zurück zum elektronischen Ausweis. Und Ben hat uns angerufen. Hallo, Ben grüßt dich. Es ist kurz vor zwölf. Dein Beitrag.
Ähm, ich hätte eine Frage. Ihr habt ja gerade gesagt, dass der Perso dann bald so aussehen wird, wie eine ganz normale Geldkarte.
Wie sieht ein Kartenformat ja?
Ja, wie eine EC-Karte so. Wird der dann noch mal irgendwie verstärkt werden?
Oder wird der...
Ist der dann genauso stabil, wie diese ganzen schönen EC-Karten?
Nee, nee, das ist eine richtige Plastikkarte.
Also, er ist genauso stabil, das ist halt eine... Genau, also so genannte ID.1-Karten. Die haben halt definierte Dimensionen, auch eine definierte Dicke und definiertes Material. Das heißt, die werden halt genau die gleiche Stabilität haben, wie auch für die Karte.
ISO 7810, glaube ich, war das.
Also, das heißt dann im Endeffekt, dass man innerhalb von drei Monaten, wenn man sich irgendwie mal ungünstig draufsetzt, dann eben schnell das Perso-Teil erstmal durchbricht.
Das kann durchaus passieren.
Und man dann wahrscheinlich einfach mal 60 Euro wieder rausschmeißen darf.
Auch das wird dann sehr wahrscheinlich der Fall sein.
Ja, das ist ja in dem Fall dann dein Problem, wenn du es irgendwie kaputt aufgesetzt. Wenn du dich aufsetzt.
Wenn man etwa diese Karte, die man heute hat, wenn man die verbrennt oder auf den Herd legt, um mal auf unseren vorherigen Anruf zurückzukommen, dann muss man natürlich auch seine eigenen Kosten tragen, wenn man den neuen dann mal antragt.
Wenn du deinen Blumentopf aus dem Fenster schmeißt, musst du ja auch einen neuen kaufen.
Das ist schon was anderes, wenn man zum Beispiel auf die elektronischen Daten drauf angewiesen ist. Das heißt, es muss ja nicht in der Mitte durchknacken, sondern es reicht, dass der Chip nicht mehr mit der Antenne verbunden ist. Das heißt, diese ganzen Zusatzfunktionen, für die wir viel Geld bezahlt haben, elektronische Unterschrift, EID, die dann nicht mehr nutzbar sind, und wer dann dafür haftet, wenn es kaputt ist, weil es ist ja eigentlich ein Herstellerfehler, dann müssten eigentlich schon andere Regeln gelten.
Das wird auch nochmal total spannend, denn eine der interessanten Zusatzfunktionen, die sie sich da so ausgedacht haben, ist, dass man es zum Beispiel in der Firma als Zutrittskontrollsystem verwenden kann. Wenn sie dann kaputt geht, dann werden wir sicherlich noch sehr viele spaßige Geschichten zu erzählen haben.
Na, da ist noch so ein Detail, was wir vielleicht auch nochmal erwähnen sollten. Man kann die besprochenen Funktionen aktivieren und deaktivieren.
Kann ich das selber machen?
Nein, wenn ich im Inland den Personalausweis beantrage, dann sage ich, ob ich es möchte. Dann wird der Hersteller mir das aktivieren.
Also ob du Fingerabdrücke drauf haben möchtest, ob du elektronische Signaturen und EID drauf haben willst.
EID aktivierst du aber bei der Ausgabe, nicht beim Hersteller.
Das ist unterschiedlich. Da unterscheiden sie zwischen inländischen und ausländischen Passantragsbehörden. Da wird es noch unterschiedliche Verfahren geben. Das ist sehr interessant. Auf jeden Fall aber müssen die Meldbehörden irgendein Gerät haben, mit dem sie diese Funktionen an- und abschalten. Das ist natürlich auch ein Sicherheitsproblem, weil es sind Tausende Behörden in gesamten Bundesgebieten und außerhalb der Bundesrepublik.
Der Punkt ist, man kann jederzeit, wenn man sich bei der Ausgabe entschieden hat, wenn man keine Fingerdrücke drauf hat, keine Signaturen usw. kann man jederzeit wieder zu Meldbeamten gehen und sagen, ich möchte es jetzt doch, aber ich hab's mir anders überlegt. Das heißt, der Chip ist zumindest für alle Meldbeamten in den 6000 Meldestellen plus Auslandsvertretung plus was weiß ich, wenn auch alles, hat Schreibrechte auf diesem Chip. Und das ist das richtig große Problem, was sie noch gar nicht angesprochen haben.
Gibt's für einen Reisepass natürlich nicht. Das ist hier also ein neues Unsicherheitsmerkmal.
Das ist halt irgendwie nix, was man mal, ja, es ist nicht so schlimm, da kann man drüber hinwegsehen. Das sind wirklich eklatante Sicherheitsprobleme und es ist mir total rätselhaft, wie sie auf die Idee gekommen sind, dass sie das überhaupt machen. Ich hab mich mit Politikern darüber unterhalten. Da hab ich gesagt, dass sie da beim Reisepass kann man immer sagen, okay, das ist zwar unsicher, aber das sind alles theoretische Angriffsmöglichkeiten. Aber hier haben sie sich so ein riesengroßes Scheuenloch eingebaut, dass es mir wirklich total unklar wäre, auf diese bescheuerte Idee gekommen ist.
Also als wir das Grobkonzept zuerst gesehen haben, da haben wir erstmal nur den Köpfen geschüttet. Also das ist ja auch nicht so, dass unser, gerade das Innenministerium, nicht kompetenter Fachleute hätte. Gerade im BSI, also im Bundesamt für Sicherheit, für die Informationstechnik, sind seit Jahren da Expertise. Denn das ist ja dieselbe Gruppe, die auch bei Preise passt, die technische Spezifikationen, die macht es mir also schleierhaft, wie sie auf die Idee kommt.
Also zum Thema, was du vorhin meintest, du findest meinen Ausweis und du hast natürlich meine PIN nicht, aber du kannst dir halt, irgendein Freund, der im Melleamt arbeitet, und das sind halt wirklich 10.000 in Deutschland, kannst du hingehen und sagen, wie setzt doch mal bitte die PIN irgendwie wieder neu, weil ich möchte jetzt irgendwie für Starbucks einkaufen gehen. Das würde gehen.
Denn wir wissen natürlich, dass Menschen Menschen sind und ihre Geheimnummern vergessen. Also das ist natürlich bekannt. Es wird nicht so selten sein, wenn Tausende Fälle sein. Denn du sind nur mal Leute, das kann man bei den Banken erfragen. Da vergessen die Leute ja auch dauernd ihre PINs. Das ist nun mal so. Menschen sind halt keine Roboter.
Und wenn du die PIN für den elektronischen Identitätsnachweis hast, dann kannst du online ein qualifiziertes elektronisches Signaturzertifikat beantragen, ohne noch mal irgendwo auftauchen zu müssen. Und hast dann eine ordentliche rechtsgültige Signatur, die identisch zur eigenhändigen Unterschrift ist, im Namen von Star Wars.
Also das ist wirklich die Katastrophe schlechthin überhaupt.
Wir haben da übrigens auch noch Benne am Telefon. Durch das du denkst, wir haben dich vergessen.
Bennes Frage war, glaube ich, hauptsächlich darauf gezielt, was passiert, wenn ich mich da draufsetze wie mit meinem Führerschein.
Und ich habe noch eine Vermutung, wie dann bald die Polizisten aussehen werden. Ich vergleiche die jetzt so langsam mit Kontrolleuren in der Bahn, dass die mit so einem Bläsegerät sich hinterher so nehmen und dadurch das Bild so vergrößert wird.
Im Zweifelsfall würde ich jetzt nur vermuten, hat der Polizeibeamte an sich da auch nicht großen Spaß dran, weil er kann doch ein weiteres Gerät mit sich rumschleppen und muss irgendwas von sich am Gürtel gehängt haben. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Danke dir, Benne.
Tschüss. Das Gerät ist natürlich auch irgendwie nicht so klein, weil da muss da ein Fingerabdrucksensor drin sein.
Über diese ganzen Dinge möchte ich jetzt gerne kurz 5 Minuten nachdenken. Hier ist Bugs.
Die National Security Agency überwacht die ganze Welt.
Faxgeräte, Telefone, Satellitenkommunikation. Sie sind die einzigen im Land einschließlich des Militärs, die über solche Geräte verfügen.
Die haben sie geortet.
Sie senden immer noch ein Signal aus ihrem Kragen, Gürtel oder Schlips. Schmeißen sie ihre Klamotten weg. Wenn sie morgen noch leben, bin ich tief beeindruckt.
Aus Hannover über Wachungsstaat von der Kriegstaggebuch Maxi. Ihr hört das Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Es ist Viertel 12, Nummer 139 sind wir. Und wir reden über den anstehenden elektronischen Personalausweis, der ab 1. November 2010 dann eingeführt wird. Wir waren auch schon beim elektronischen Reisepass quasi. Der kleine Vorläufer und Testballon für das, was dann später der Ausweis werden wird. Der kostet im Moment 60 Euro. Allerdings nicht für Micha, der hat mehr bezahlt. Hallo Micha.
Guten Abend. Also, ich hatte einen Job-Aniveau, den ich in Florida für 10 Tage hatte. Und da musste ich meinen Bürgeramt schnell mir einen Reisepass machen lassen. E-Pass. Für den USA soll E-Pass sein.
Schon mit Fingerabdrucken oder nur Geschichtsmit?
Ja, alles mit Fingerabdruck und biometrisches Foto.
Oha, erzähl mal.
Naja, 91 Euro.
Nicht den Preis, erzähl mal erstmal die Prozedur.
Naja, Finger offen, also alle fünf Finger mussten, also nicht, also keine Finger musste auch mit drauf.
Was?
Dann haben die wieder nicht richtig gelesen, okay.
Warum haben sie deine Finger, also warum haben sie überhaupt mehr als ein Anzeigefinger abgenommen? Also war die Qualität zu schlecht oder was?
Nee, die machen die generell.
Nee.
Okay, also beschreib mal, du kommst dahin und dann haben sie dir den Fingerabdruckscanner vor die Nase gesetzt und dann haben sie das bitte einmal auflegen, ja?
Das bitte einmal auflegen und das gleich, das hat, das Ding scannt ja glaube ich drei Mal durch pro Finger. Das hat eine ganze Weile gedauert.
Das heißt, du hast da 30 Mal deine Finger auflegen müssen?
Deswegen dauert es so lange.
Na ja, das ist nicht unbedingt so vorgesehen. Wenn du das so machen kannst, kannst du ja als Bürger nicht wissen, wie lange hat das etwa gedauert, bis du dann endlich mal die Fingerabdrücke alle ausgelesen hatten?
Also, wissen wir, das war eine Weile, ja, weil das hat bestimmt eine Viertelstunde gedauert oder so, alles.
Boah, aber dann will ich mal den Ausweis auslesen. Also, ich meine, wenn die halt wirklich alle abgenommen haben und alle in dem Pass gespeichert sind, kommst du aus Berlin?
Dann könntest du uns hier mal besuchen.
Genau, schreib uns doch mal eine Mail. Also, das ist echt kurios, weil es sollte eigentlich nicht so sein und wenn dem so ist, dann wollen wir auf jeden Fall mal sehen, was auf dem Pass dann wirklich gespeichert ist.
Die Frage wäre ja auch jetzt gewesen, wie sieht das aus für Arbeitslose, wenn die jetzt ein Jobangebot haben?
Weil du so viel bezahlt hast, meinst du?
Wir zahlten den.
Du selber? Achso, vielleicht noch mal zum Hinweis, du hast 91 Euro statt 59 bezahlt, weil das halt ein Expresspass ist. Also du hast dann gesagt, du brauchst den halt irgendwie sofort und deswegen bezahlt man halt diesen Aufpreis von 90 Euro.
Aber was ist denn, wenn er jetzt dieses Jahr oder nächstes Jahr soll er ja irgendwie Standard werden? Wir zahlten den dann.
Wieso nicht?
Der Personalausweis wird ja auch nicht von mir aus bezahlt. Jeder, der irgendwie von Jobcenter oder von Arbeitsamt Geld bekommt, der kann zum Bürgeramt gehen und kriegt ihn umsonst. Und wenn ich den verlieren soll, dann...
Das ist eine Frage, die du dann glaube ich direkt mit deinem Berater beim Arbeitsamt erklären musst.
Wir wissen das auch wirklich nicht.
Also das war mir auch total neu, dass du die nicht selber bezahlst.
Also normalerweise ist es ja so, dass der Ausweis ein Dokument ist, den du als Bürger haben musst, egal ob jetzt Pass oder aber Ausweis, eins von beiden musst du ja haben und da bist du dann verpflichtet, dir das Ding auch zu besorgen. Aber das müsstest du echt mal mit den zuständigen Leuten bei deinem Amt besprechen, wie das dann bei dem Ausweis sein wird. Ich würde jetzt ganz ins Blaue und ohne das genaue Wissen, genau zu wissen, würde vermuten, dass die in so einem Fall die Kosten natürlich auch übernehmen. Es sei denn, es ist wie in deinem Fall jetzt ein Expresspass, der schneller gehen muss und der ist natürlich teurer. Aber da sind wir glaube ich nicht die Experten.
Aber wobei, das ist vielleicht nochmal eine Sache, die wir erwähnen sollten. Wir nehmen den Paß und den Personalausweis, es ist auch noch ein drittes Projekt gestartet. Nämlich, es gibt jetzt auch die elektronische Aufenthaltskarte. Damit haben sie auch tatsächlich die gesamte Bevölkerung erfasst.
Was ist eine?
Wenn Sie zu sagen, auch so lange hier sind, dann kriegen Sie so eine Aufenthaltskarte. Also wenn Sie eben zum Beispiel hier arbeiten und für zwei, fünf oder zehn Jahre eben eine Aufenthaltsgenehmigung haben, dann kriegen Sie auch so eine Karte. Das heißt, die werden auch biometrisch erfasst. Damit haben Sie echt so die Gesamtbevölkerung.
Das heißt, alle Leute, die innerhalb der Grenze sind, die hast du irgendwie erfasst?
Also bei Asylbewerbungen haben sie ja schon ganz zum Anfang. Also Asylbewerbungen waren praktisch so die ersten Testläufer, die alle Fingerabdrücke abgeben mussten, Gesichtsbilder und so weiter. Dann haben sie jetzt halt die normalen Leute und natürlich auch die Langzeitausländer, die hier wohnen.
Okay, Michael, ich hoffe, wir haben deine Frage jetzt zwar nicht beantwortet, aber vielleicht einen Hinweis gegeben, wo du dich nachhin wenden kannst.
Mal kurz eine zweite Frage. Macht ihr heute nur mit Sicherheit und mit Fingerabdrücken so ein bisschen Wirt?
Eigentlich ist Biometrie und der Personalausweis unser Thema. Wieso?
Na, weil ein Bekannter von mir, der hat letztens einen Vaterschaftstest machen müssen mit Lichtbild und Fingerabdruck.
Wie, er musste sein biometrisches Bild abgeben?
Nee, ein biometrisches Bild nicht. Das war ein ganz normales Foto, wurde von ihm geschossen und ein Fingerabdruck wurde genommen.
Als Vaterschaftstest.
Als Vaterschaftstest oder als Beweis dafür, dass er er ist? Nee, das hat er noch die DNA abgegeben.
Also denke mal, dafür hat derjenige auch sein Personalausweis, aber trotzdem musste er ein Fingerabdruck und ein Lichtbild abgeben.
Wo war das?
In Berlin.
Nee, welches, also Krankenhaus, oder?
Kinderarzt.
Aber die haben ja noch kein Fingerabdrucksensor beim Arzt.
Nee, das war auch nicht mit dem Scanner, wie man meint, sondern mit Tinte.
Im Zweifelsfall auch mal beim Arzt fragen, warum die das machen, dann müsste der Arzt ja auch die Tinte drücken.
Ich hab noch keinen Arzt gesehen, der einen Stempelkissen hat.
Kann ich dir genauer sagen, und zwar hat er da irgendwie mit einem Darkshots-Beauftragten in Sachsen telefoniert. Die wollten jetzt erstmal ja eine Globen, die wollten dann alle Schriftdokumente haben. Aber laut Robert-Koch-Institut soll es irgendwie dahergehen, weil er kann ja jenen hinschicken.
Ja, aber was wollen Sie dann mit einem Stempelkissen-Fingerabdruck?
Also ich mein, dafür hat er seinen Ausweis dabei, um halt zu zeigen, also seine Identität darzustellen. Das ist halt irgendwie genau dafür, wo der Ausweis für da ist.
Okay, wir sind aber heute eher bei der elektronischen Variante und nicht bei der Tintenvariante. Aber Micha, wenn du da irgendwie noch mehr Infos brauchst, einfach mal Mail schicken an Chaosradio.rccc.de. Vielleicht kann man das irgendwie noch weiterleiten. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Telefonnummer vom Chaosradio. Auf Fritz der Nächste am Telefon ist Sophia oder Sophias? Sophias. Ein griechischer oder bulgarischer Name?
Das ist eine Variante von Sophia plus auf Lojban. Also mein Problem, was ich ein bisschen mit der ganzen Frage, allgemein Pässe und Datenschutz und so habe, ist, dass es immer so letztendlich, also ich frag mich, inwiefern es unbedingt legitim ist, dass der Staat im Prinzip jeder Informationen mehr oder weniger bekommen kann, die er letztendlich haben will, weil...
Ach so, also dass du dich sozusagen damit abfinden musst, dass der Staat sagt, ich hätte gerne von dir die und die und die und die Daten und du kannst nicht sagen, nein will ich nicht.
Ich meine, es gibt die Meldeamter und da weißt du ja schon mal, auch ohne Biometrie und alles, wo ich wohne, wie ich heiße und überhaupt und...
Ja, die Biometrie ist jetzt auch quasi nur noch das Sahnehäubchen oben drauf und derzeit ist es so, dass sie sich nicht mal Mühe gegeben haben, irgendwie zu begründen, warum jetzt die Biometrie auch in diesen Personalausweis kommt. Bei dem Reisepass haben sie ja immer noch von Sicherheit und so gelabert, was man natürlich auch an da fragen kann, aber beim Personalausweis haben sie nicht mehr eine richtige Begründung dafür. Und durch die Hintertür wird mit diesem neuen Personalausweisgesetz ja auch noch eben das Online-Abrufverfahren, dass man eben auch online auf diese Daten zugreifen kann, wenn man eine Sicherheitsbehörde ist. Oder eben generell der Automatisierte-Abgleich-ID-Sitz wird ja mit eingeführt. Wir haben das vorhin eigentlich nur relativ kurz erwähnt, aber das ist natürlich für uns auch eine entscheidende Frage. Das ist ja ein Trend, klar, wir sind ja nur seit Jahren, dass da irgendwie die Datensammlung des Staates ausgebaut werden. Hier ist es eigentlich so, dass sich kaum Mühe gegeben haben, das noch irgendwie zu begründen.
Also vor allem halt nicht nur für irgendwelche kriminellen oder Abgleich mit kriminellen Datenbanken, sondern es geht halt zum Beispiel auch darum festzustellen, wenn du halt falsch gepackt, also Ordnungswidrigkeiten falsch packen, zu schnell fahren. Und wenn du irgendwie dessen verdächtigt wirst, kann die Polizei sagen, wir wollen jetzt mal irgendwie online auf diese Daten zugreifen, die du halt eigentlich dazu abgeben musstest, um deinen Ausweis überhaupt zu kriegen.
Und das sind sogar noch mehr als nur die Verkehrsordnungswidrigkeiten, das soll erweitert werden. Zum einen auf den ganzen Bereich Gefahren, Abwehr, kennen wir ja schon. Es ist sozusagen immer sehr wichtig, aber auch auf sonstige Ordnungswidrigkeiten. Das war doch einigermaßen erschreckend, denn es gibt eine ganze Latte an Ordnungswidrigkeiten, so Schmutz hinwerfen, Hund nicht anmelden, all diese Zeug, die jetzt plötzlich auch noch dazugehören, wenn man eben diesen Online-Abruf machen will.
Aber es ist doch super, es ist doch viel einfacher, es ist doch ganz praktisch, es ist doch toll.
Ja, was ich bloß vielleicht mal ein bisschen als Position, als Statement geben würde, ist es doch ein bisschen, weil die Sache ist immer, es wird so, die Daten, es ist irgendwie das, ich würde es zu Angst machen, einerseits schon, dass im Prinzip jede Daten, die irgendwo rumliegen, schon als Bedrohung empfunden werden und andererseits Daten einfach mal zwangsweise genommen werden, weil sonst, ich weiß nicht, was passiert, wenn man den Personalausweis ablehnt oder...
Nee, du kannst den Personalausweis nicht ablehnen. Also du musst ein gültiges Dokument haben und das ist entweder der Reisepass oder der Ausweis und dann kannst du sagen, nein, nein, nein, will ich nicht, aber du wirst ihn haben müssen, weil es ist...
Ja, sonst wäre ich schon eingeliefert oder weiß ich nicht.
Na du brauchst ihn doch einfach, wenn du zum Beispiel ein Konto aufmachen willst, dann nur Mietvertrag unterschreibst, also du brauchst dieses Dokument in Deutschland einfach, also eins von beiden.
Also das ist ja nicht zufällig, dass es da Staate draus gibt, denn das ist halt ja auch ein hoheitliches Dokument. Und man kommt im normalen Leben, also wenn man jetzt noch nicht versucht, sich irgendwie so legal in Deutschland rumzudrücken, man kommt nicht drum rum, denn einige Rechtsgeschäfte kann man ohne schlicht nicht mehr machen. Also Bank ist halt so typisch.
Mietertrag, gutes Beispiel.
Ja, manche Vermieter machen zwar nicht alle, aber in der Regel wollen die auch einen Ausweis nehmen. Manche beim Handyvertrag.
Genau, für alle möglichen Dinge musst du einen Ausweis haben. Also da führt irgendwie kein Weg dran vorbei.
Mein Problem ist eben genau das Hoheitliche. Und dagegen kann man vielleicht nicht viel tun. Aber wenn es jetzt irgendwie, sagen wir mal, private Pässe oder irgendwas geben würde, dann könnte sich einfach jeder selber raussuchen. Und irgendwie, dann könnten nicht einfach irgendwelche Melder einfach mal, ups, wir haben hier Daten wirklich.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt eine sehr zusammen konstruierte Theorie, weil natürlich braucht der Staat als quasi als Herrscher des Landes, in dem du lebst, muss sich um dich kümmern und da kann nicht jeder irgendwie seine Ausweise ausgeben. Das ist Quatsch. Aber ich gebe dir recht in dem Moment, wo du sagst, man kann schon mal über den Punkt nachdenken, warum gibt es das eigentlich alles und sich einfach tiefer in die Materie einlesen.
Man kann vor allem auch mal, man kann mal was überlegen, für alle Gelder, die sich jetzt an irgendwann einen machen müssen. Man kann überlegen, das abzuwählen, weil derzeit ist das noch optional und man kann einfach sagen, nein, wenn eine überwiegende Mehrzeit das macht, wäre das eine tolle Sache, denke ich.
Ja, also das auf jeden Fall, wenn man halt noch die Wahl hat, dann zumindest schon mal die Wahl auch wahrnehmen und dem Staat damit zeigen, dass man nicht damit einverstanden ist, dass er diese Daten wirklich sammelt und dann irgendwo hinstellt.
Okay, danke dir, der nächste ist am Telefon ist Oliver. Hallo Oliver, guten Abend. Das ist zu hören.
Ich hab meinen Ausweis schon auch mit Singerabdrücken.
Uh, erzähl mal.
So einen richtig neuen elektronischen Ausweis?
Ja, ja. Also ich bin so ein Early Adopter. Also ich hab das beides gebraucht.
Ein Early Adopter, wie du das gelernt hast.
Ich wollte Dinge haben. Und ich hab mich da schon so ein bisschen vorbereitet, dass ich mal ein paar abwachsen lassen. Das Foto hab ich dann machen lassen. Sehr geil. Drei Monate so richtig spriefen lassen. Und shapeen, also dass das Gesicht so ein bisschen verformt wird. Ich bin eigentlich relativ dick und dann bin ich auf einmal wieder schlank oder das Gesicht ist länger gezogen. Dann hab ich meine Brillenbügel nach vorne gebogen, dass ich auf einmal siegelohren hab. Also ich weiß nicht, man sieht das schon irgendwie.
Du hast aber wirklich immer A dafür, subversiv. Das ist aber schön, da bist du nicht mal notiert. Ja, gerade in Bayern, wo sie ja bei der Polizei über 300 von diesen Car-PCs haben, also diese ausgestatteten Polizeivagen, die später deinen Ausweis auslesen sollen.
Aber an der Stelle Oliver, du kannst gleich weitermachen, an der Stelle der Einwurf von mir oder die Frage, wenn ich irgendwie hingehe und mir einen Bart wachsen lasse und mir die Ohren nach vorne schiebe und so weiter und so fort, da kann niemand sagen, ich hab sie die letzte Woche aber gesehen, sie sehen ganz anders aus, oder? Oder wir haben hier ein altes Ton von ihr?
Na ja, ich muss mich halt selber wieder hätten, damit ich dann wieder so ausschaue wie auf dem Bild.
Das ist ja toll.
Also ich brauchte eine gewisse Vorlaufzeit.
Hat dann dein Foto gleich funktioniert, also haben sie es gleich akzeptiert?
Das war überhaupt kein Problem.
Und die Finger?
Das war so richtig so im Fotostudio. Ja, ich hab die Wand gestreichelt. Also ich hab so ein bisschen verputzt und wir sehen uns an der Wand.
Wollt ihr euch mal ein bisschen benehmen, so bei derselbe Tisch der Umfeld?
Ach, er hat mit uns gemeckert, weil wir so viel lachen. Einfach nicht irritieren lassen.
Das ist ja auch wirklich zum Lachen, wenn es nicht zum Meinen wäre. Und dann hab ich mir gedacht, also um eben fast noch die Krone aufzusetzen, muss ich irgendwas, ich hab da mal was gehört, ein paar Hagelfeile und über die Fingerkuppen. Und ich dachte, also die Geschichte mit dem So und So Kreuz, das geht ja nicht, aber ein Nummerenteilchen. Also ich hab das halt mal so ein bisschen gemacht. Ich hab mir gedacht, ich darf da auch nicht übertreiben, sonst steh ich da stundenlang und effektbar im Grunde genommen. Ich hab beide Zeigesinger aufgelegt und wahrscheinlich machen beide das Nummerenteilchen schön.
Konntest du den Bild schon nicht einsehen? Hast du nicht gesehen?
Nee, aber ich hab ihn danach gesagt. Sie wissen schon, dass ihr Rechner so da steht, dass ich hinten dran USB-Stick einstecken kann. Ich hatte dann schon ziemlich verwirrt. Habt ihr nicht verstanden.
Was meinst du eigentlich mit Nummerenteilchen?
Ja, ich hab mit der Nagelfeile dann morgen, bevor ich dahingegangen bin, noch so ein bisschen rumgefeilt. Das sollte dann so, also zweimal rechts, zweimal vertikal, zweimal horizontal.
Oh man, mir geht ja echt gerne ein Foto davon.
Ja, ich weiß ja nicht, was dabei ausgekommen ist. Also ich kriege ja kein Foto von meinem Fingerabdruck.
Naja, aber du kannst ja wohl irgendwie mit deinem Reisepass ins Meldeamt gehen und sagen, du möchtest jetzt mal die Fingerabdruckbilder sehen. Also du gibst ihnen halt einen Reisepass und sie legen ihn auf das Gerät und müssen dir zeigen, was da für Daten drauf gespeichert sind.
Wir haben das schon häufiger gemacht, denn alle Meldeämter halten dies vor. Wir haben uns ja zum Beispiel, gibt ja einige Menschen, die haben sich unsere Schäuble-Attrappe auf die Finger geklebt. Und wir sind in die Meldeämter gegangen und haben dann auch die Bildschirme fotografiert, um beweisen zu können, dass da wirklich ein Schäubleabdruck drauf ist. Das kannst du auch tun und dir ein schickes Foto machen von deinen Abdrücken.
Ja, das habe ich mich da nicht so getraut, weil ich gedacht habe, wenn ich da nochmal hinkomme, vielleicht behalten sie mich gleich.
Ach komm, du warst doch so cool mit deinem Bart. Dann kannst du da wohl auch mal ein Foto machen.
Wir hätten das gerne.
Du kannst doch nach Berlin kommen, dann machen wir das für dich.
Nach Berlin? Da war ich noch nie. Das wäre noch viel gefährlicher.
Stimmt.
Der Witz war das, dass ich dann probiert hab, so ein bisschen Diskussionen anzufangen. Nach dem Motto Freiheit kann verteidigt werden, dadurch, dass sie beschränkt wird.
Das kam bestimmt nicht gut an.
Nee, das war komisch. Zuerst waren drei Leute da. Ich hab dann auch schon überlegt, wo der Knopf ist, weil auf einmal waren fünf Leute da. Ja, so schlimm war es nicht. Es standen alle vor mir. Aber ich kenne die Leute. Ich bin öfters eine kleine Gemeinde. Ich hab dann schon probiert, so ein bisschen zu diskutieren. Es gibt diese Geschichte mit diesen Hollerit-Karten, wo vor x Jahren schon mal eine Volksstehlung gemacht worden ist. Irgendso ein Bösewicht hat es dann benutzt, weil da auch die Religionszugehörigkeit benutzt worden ist. Also auch gespeichert worden ist. Und ich hab solche Argumente probiert anzubringen und hab danach auch eben auch erzählt, was ist denn. Also es hat geheißen, ja, aber das ist ja alles sicher. Und das kann ja niemand auslesen. Und dann hab ich gesagt, wie ist das im Ausland? Und wenn dann diese Daten rücktransferiert werden. Und die Leute waren mehr als beratungsresistent. Also die wollten das eigentlich gar nicht. Ich meine, das ist ja klar, wir sind Beamte und die müssen ihren Job machen.
Aber im Endeffekt hast du schon problemlos deinen Pass dann gekriegt.
Naja, natürlich ist irgendwie so ein Meldeamt ja auch die falsche Stelle. Die Beamten können dann wirklich in der Regel nichts dafür. Und sind auch oft mit der Technik selber ziemlich überfordert. Aber dass die Bürger ihrem Unmut da Luft machen, finde ich schon richtig. Ich habe mich darüber sehr geärgert, dass der IT-Direktor im BMI kürzlich auf so einer Veranstaltung sagte, es gebe überhaupt gar keine Probleme auf dem Meldeamt. Es läuft alles wie geschmiert. Das ist nicht so, denn wir hören immer wieder die Geschichten. Das sollte das auch sagen, dass Ihnen das nicht gefällt. Und wenn Sie Glück haben, müssen Sie die ganze Sache wieder einrollen.
Das war ganz eindeutig, dass mir das nicht passt, weil ich gesagt habe, das ist meiner Meinung nach einfach nicht sicher. Es ist auch meiner Meinung nach eine Unverschämtheit wegen Generalverdacht usw. Für mich persönlich ist es so, gerade mit dem Foto, ich habe da eben so Sachen gesehen aus London, was da eben schon Software soweit ist, dass man einfach innerhalb von Bruchteilen, von Sekunden also diese Kontur oder das biometrische Bild zu bestimmten Daten zuordnen kann. Und es geht ja nicht nur darum, dass wir irgendwo unsere Fingerabdrücke hinterlassen, sondern dass wir irgendwo spazieren gehen und die wissen, wer wir sind.
Also das ist natürlich irgendwie die Träume, die sie nachher wirklich alle haben, dass du halt mit den Daten von den Personalausweisen dann halt alle Leute auf der Straße verfolgen kannst. Das funktioniert derzeit noch nicht, aber...
Es ist nicht wirklich mehr ein Traum. Immerhin machen, also der 1 zu N-Abgleich mit den 4 Millionen Datensätzen, die in der ARFIS-Datenbank sind, der ist schon gefordert. Also es ist nicht mehr so, dass wir über eine Zukunft von in 10 Jahren reden.
Olli, weil wir müssen jetzt Nachrichten machen, ein Wort vielleicht noch... Ein Wort vielleicht noch an dich als Abschluss. Wärst du kein First Adopter, hättest du jetzt das ganze Theater nicht. Aber du musstest es ja alle vorne weg haben.
Ich freu mich ja drauf. Ich nenne das ja irgendwie so Personalausweis-Hacking oder so was. Ich sag mal, ich mein, für mich ist es so, die wissen eigentlich nicht, wie ich ausschaue. Und wenn ich unbedingt meinen Ausweis brauch, dann muss ich mich halt wieder verkleiden, damit ich Spaß und so weiter habe.
Oder du kannst den Chip deaktivieren, dann hat sich das eh erledigt.
Ich hab mir überlegt, ob ich das nicht anders machen soll. Ich lass ihn jetzt noch so wie er ist und dann reise ich aus. Und dann tu ich ihn deaktivieren und vielleicht darf ich da nicht mehr einreisen.
Viel Spaß bei den Clowns. Servus nach Bayern.
Tschau. Die Popkom. Kommt. Vom 8. bis 10. Oktober. Da ist Fritz wieder das Radio zur Popkom. Und präsentiert das Popkom Festival. Jede Menge gute neue Musik in Berlin. Zum Beispiel neue Musik mit den Labels Cityslang und Wichita. Get well soon.
Die Bundesregierung hat ein 3 Milliarden-Hilfspaket für die deutschen Krankenhäuser auf den Weg gebracht. Mit dem Geld könnten in den nächsten drei Jahren 21.000 zusätzliche Pflegekräfte eingestellt werden, sagte Gesundheitsministerin Schmidt. Den Klinikbetreibern reicht das nicht. Sie sehen die flächendeckende Versorgung und Arbeitsplätze in Gefahr. Die Krankenkassen kritisieren, dass nur die Versicherten für das Milliardenpaket aufkommen müssten. Alle sieben Vorstandsmitglieder der KfW-Bank sind wegen Untreue angezeigt worden. Das teilte die Staatsanwaltschaft in Frankfurt am Main mit. Die KfW hatte der US-Bank Lehman Brothers 350 Millionen Euro überwiesen, obwohl das US-Institut zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon zahlungsunfähig war. Den beiden suspendierten Vorständen werden nach KfW-Angaben ihre Bezüge von insgesamt 600.000 Euro weitergezahlt. Wer sich beruflich verbessern und aufsteigen will, soll besser gefördert werden. Die Bundesregierung hat dafür heute die Regelungen zum Meister-Bafig geändert. In Zukunft bezahlt der Staat bei erfolgreicher Abschlussprüfung fast die Hälfte der Kurs- und Prüfungsgebühren, bisher ist es knapp ein Drittel. Außerdem sollen neben Handwerkern und anderen Fachkräften jetzt auch Altenpfleger und Erzieher bei der Fortbildung finanziell unterstützt werden. Der republikanische US-Präsidentschaftskandidat McCain will seinen Wahlkampf wegen der internationalen Finanzkrise unterbrechen. Außerdem wolle er das für Freitag geplante Fernseh-Duell mit seinem Rivalen Obama verschieben, sagte McCain in New York. Die neuesten Meinungsumfragen haben ergeben, dass der demokratische Kandidat Obama offensichtlich von den Turbulenzen auf dem US-Bankensektor profitiert. Obama käme derzeit auf 52 Prozent der Stimmen, der Republikaner McCain würde dagegen nur 43 Prozent erreichen. Hertha BSC hat das Achtelfinale des DFB-Pokals verpasst, die Berliner verloren am Abend bei Borussia Dortmund nach Verlängerung mit 1 zu 2. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen potzt es am Neuropin 10 Grad, Wittenberg, Angermünde 11, Frankfurt 12, Cottbus 13 und in Berlin sind es derzeit 11 Grad. Heute Nacht ist es stellenweise bewirkt, in einigen Gegenden gibt es aber auch einen sternen, klaren Himmel. Regnen soll es heute Nacht aber nicht. Es bleibt also überall trocken. Das Thermometer sinkt heute Nacht bis auf 6 Grad. Morgen wird es tagsüber wieder sonnig, ohne Regen und das bei ziemlich Müllen 18 Grad. Vier Meldungen immer noch. AC, nördlicher Berliner Ringrichtung, Dreieck-Schwanenberg. Zwischen Dreieck-Haveland und dem Kreuz Oranienburg fährt ein Schwertransporter, den könnt ihr nicht überholen. A114, Zubinger-Pankow statt auswärts zwischen schöner Linda-Straße und dem Dreieck-Pankow liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Dort solltet ihr eure Augen also besser offen lassen. Und dann noch zwei Mellons im Stadtverkehr Berlin. A100 statt in Richtung Wedding. Zwischen der Albuinstraße und dem Hohenzollerndamm ist wegen Bauarbeiten die linke Spur gesperrt. Und A115, A115-Zubinger-Nutetal statt auswärts Richtung Dreieck-Hotztam. Zwischen dem Dreieck-Funkturm und dem Hüttenweg ist die rechte Spur gesperrt. Dort wird gebaut. Ansonsten allen, die noch unterwegs sind, eine gute Fahrt.
Und wir möchten euch natürlich darum bitten, auf allen Straßen, auf denen ihr unterwegs seid, sowohl in Berlin als auch in Brandenburg, als auch da, wo ihr sonst Fritz hört, die Augen generell offen zu halten, ist besser.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz in Eberswalde.
Blum, die Zeitsprechstunden.
Die Frau, die das Lied von Gollum gesungen hat, ist jetzt wieder da mit einem neuen Album. Abimi heißt es, das neue Album von Emeliana Turini. Davon habt ihr gerade gehört. I heard it all before, was wunderbar auch zum Thema der heutigen Chaosradio Sendung passt. Wir reden über den elektronischen Personalausweis. Wir hatten auch schon als Thema den elektronischen Reisepass. Da haben wir ausführlich darüber geredet, wo die Risiken und Gefahren liegen. Und jetzt kommt der elektronische Ausweis und alles scheint von vorne loszugehen. Wir haben schon ein bisschen erklärt, wo die Probleme liegen, wie das Ding funktionieren wird. Und es ist das Stichwort gefallen, online-Abgleich. Das heißt, ich bin irgendwo unterwegs, zwischen hier Dorf und da Dorf. Und nein, Konstanze Schlüttenkopf, ganz anders.
Das wäre ja dieser automatisierte Abgleich. Aber der online-Abruf ist zu sagen die Möglichkeit, online, also irgendwie über das Netz, auf diese Daten in den Meldebehörden zuzugreifen.
Kann ich das als Privatmensch auch?
Nee, das ist nicht vorgesehen. Das soll natürlich irgendwie hoheitlich bleiben. Das ist auch so geplant. Das haben sie eingeführt zum Reisepass. Da war es erst mal so, dass wenn die zuständige Ausweisbehörde eben oder die Paßbehörde nicht erreichbar ist, also etwa an den Wochenenden und nach den Öffnungszeiten, dann konnte dieses Online-Abruf-Verfahren gestartet werden. Jetzt haben sie sich gesagt, ist eigentlich überhaupt nicht so eine tolle Idee, wenn wir jetzt das Personalausweisgesetz machen, dann schreiben wir da gleich mal rein, da kann jetzt immer online zugegriffen werden. Auch so durch die Hintertür wird da plötzlich diese neue Regelung eingeführt. Und zusätzlich, was ich vorhin schon erwähnt hatte, eben jetzt nicht nur für Verkehrsaordnungswürdigkeiten, sondern auch gleich noch zur Gefahrenabwehr und für eben sonstige Ordnungswürdigkeiten. Das war so ein Kritikpunkt, wo wir uns eigentlich wundern, wo sie plötzlich mit diesen Forderungen da wieder herkommen.
Also sie hatten halt bisher schon immer die Möglichkeit, wenn sie ein Gesicht zu einer Person haben wollten, halt irgendwie zu sagen, wir brauchen das, dann haben sie halt irgendwie einen Brief bzw. einen Fax gekriegt und haben das angeglichen und waren halt glücklich. Was sie jetzt tun und was die große Gefahr ist, sie können es halt wirklich automatisiert und irgendwie ohne großartige Gründe machen. Das heißt, irgendwie sie klicken auf den Knopf und haben gleich irgendwie 1000 Bilder und das ist halt irgendwie wirklich die Gefahr, dass halt einfach dann, dass halt so vereinfacht wird, dass es halt einfach wirklich missbräuchlich benutzt werden wird.
Es geht ja auch um die Erkennungssysteme, denn sie haben ja nicht eher so ein Datenblatt, was aus einem Fax fällt mit einem Gesicht drauf, sondern ist natürlich ein digitales Bild, was man noch weiterverarbeiten kann und das hat die Gefahr.
Und halt auch dieser automatische Abgleich ist halt schon, dass sie alle Leute, die sie erst mal gegen diese eine Person abgleichen, halt schon unter den Verdacht erst mal stellen, dass die eine Straftat begangen haben, was hat ja irgendwie rechtlich auch Problematisches.
Naja, und weil wir beim Reisepass jedes Jahr wieder gefragt haben, was eigentlich uns der ganze Spaß dann insgesamt kostet und wir bis heute nicht wissen, denn die Bundesregierung hat einfach keine Kostenkalkulation gemacht, bis heute nicht, fängt dieser Spaß natürlich wieder jetzt an für den elektronischen Personalausweis. Und da die Kommunen doch einige Summen draufgelegt haben für den Reisepass, hat jetzt der Bundesrat gesagt, also so jetzt aber nicht, jetzt soll es so sein, dass bei dem Ausweis die Kosten des Dokuments, also die derjenige, der beantragt trägt, tatsächlich auch die Kosten decken sollen.
Was heißt das? Was kostet der Ausweis dann? Ist das schon klar?
Das ist noch nicht klar. Aber auf jeden Fall hat der Bundesrat die Bundesregierung aufgefordert, das alles vorher offen zu legen. Da sind wir natürlich gespannt, ob wir diese mal ein bisschen neue Zahlen bekommen, denn wir haben einfach keine von Reisepass.
Also zum Thema offenlegen, was halt beim Reisepass war, ist halt so, dass sie zum Anfang relativ offen waren mit ihrer, mit ihren Informationen, also jetzt mal abgesehen vom Geld, aber dann halt als Kritik aufgekommen ist, halt relativ schnell zurückgerudert sind. Es gab halt wirklich Aussagen vom BMI, also von Schili damals, der seinen Untergehenden verboten hat, über dieses Thema zu sprechen. Und beim Reise- beim Personalausweis haben sie halt draus gelernt, naja, gelernt wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall war da gleich von Anfang an klar, es gibt keine Informationen. Also wir haben genau zwei Paper, also zwei Dokumente zu dem Thema, die auch so verschleppt rausgegeben wurden. Genau, die eigentlich auch teilweise nicht wirklich öffentlich sind, die wir halt irgendwie aus anderen Quellen haben, halt so vom BSI, vom BMI. Aber da ist halt die Informationspolitik noch viel eingeschränkter als beim Reisepass.
Und gleichzeitig wird aber auch verlockt, dass ja diesmal die Presse nicht so schlecht sei und offenbar die Idee mit dem Personalausweis ganz gut ankäme. Natürlich gibt er auch keine großartigen Informationen. Wer hat das gesagt? Der IT-Direktor Schallbruch wieder, mein spezieller Freund, der bei den Veranstaltungen, wenn man ihn da halt sprechen hört, hört sich das immer alles so an, als ob er problemlos läuft, überhaupt kein Sicherheitsproblem ist, obwohl er natürlich IT-Expertisen, die natürlich auch schriftlich gibt und die in den Expertenanhörungen im Bundestag ja auch verschriftlicht wurden, die gibt es, die sollten ihm auch bekannt sein. Aber er tut so, als wenn man ein super tolles, erfolgreiches Projekt jetzt noch mal für den Ausweis wiederholt.
Also echt eine Unverschämtheit schlechthin.
Aber die ganzen Kritikpunkte, die sowohl am elektronischen Reisepass als auch am elektronischen Ausweis von Datenschützern und von vielen anderen kommen.
Vor allem auch Sicherheitsprobleme.
Sicherheitsprobleme, rechtliche Probleme, moralische Probleme, alles was da so dazugehört. Finden die in irgendeiner Form Gehör? Gibt es da eine Entwicklung, dass die entsprechenden herausgebenden Behörden und Stellen sagen, ok, darüber denken wir nochmal nach oder ist jeglicher Ärger umsonst?
Das ist interessanterweise sogar so. Je mehr Kritik kommt, desto tauber werden sie. Also es gab halt diese Anhörung im Bundestag, wo eigentlich sämtliche Experten, also wirklich auch die eigenen des BSI, also der, der halt irgendwie beim Bundesinnenministerium dafür zuständig ist für die technische Analyse. Sie haben halt alle gesagt, da gibt es halt wirklich Probleme, ihr könnt das so nicht einführen. Und im Endeffekt haben sie es halt eingeführt, ohne großartig darüber zu studieren. Also da war es halt wirklich sehr deutlich, dass sie halt alle Experten, alle Expertenmeinungen einfach mal unter den Tisch gefallen lassen haben.
Okay, vielleicht abschließend nochmal die Frage, die viele Leute auch beschäftigt, die die Sendung heute gehört haben. Kann ich irgendwas machen, wenn ich diesen Ausweis nicht haben will?
Nein, man wird ein elektronisches Ausweisdokument haben müssen. Was wir empfehlen ist, sich vielleicht doch dieses funkenden, kontaktlosen Mikroships zu entledigen.
Oder ansonsten Ausweis jetzt noch beantragen und verlängern, dann gilt das Ding nämlich zehn Jahre.
Genau, beim Ausweis geht das ja.
Ihr seid erst mal für die nächsten zehn Jahre von diesem Thema nicht betroffen. Denn ab dem 1. November 2010, also im nächsten Jahr im November, ist der elektronische Personalausweis dann auch Pflicht und wird dann eingeführt. Das heißt nicht, dass ihr eure Ausweise umtauschen müsst automatisch, sondern wenn die Dinger ablaufen, dann kriegt ihr dann einen elektronischen.
Eine Sache wäre dann noch angekündigt, ist ja, dass in dem Zeitraum jetzt zwischen der Einführung und jetzt noch Probeläufe und auch größere Tests stattfinden. Da sind wir doch sehr gespannt drauf und wir hoffen doch sehr, dass aufgrund dieses super erfolgreichen Projekts die Ergebnisse dann auch öffentlich werden.
Wir werden euch auf jeden Fall über die weiteren Entwicklungen in Sachen elektronischer Ausweis informieren. Ihr könnt diese Sendung und viele andere natürlich als Podcast hören und euch in Ruhe noch mal reinziehen unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Da gibt es auch alle anderen Sendungen, noch mal als Podcast zu hören. Da gibt es auch das Chaosradio Express, die etwas technischere Variante vom Chaosradio, was ihr auch hören könnt, was der Tim macht. Und alle weiteren Infos rund um den Chaos Computer Club. Und damit würde ich jetzt gerne das Buch um den elektronischen Ausweis zumachen und noch ein paar andere Sachen ansprechen, die noch vor der Tür stehen. Nämlich zum einen ist Blinkenlights da und es kommt auch noch ein Datengarten.
Also, Tim war schon mal das richtige Schlagwort. Es gibt wieder Blinkenlights, leider ganz schön weit weg. Und zwar so fast auf der anderen Seite des Wert-El-Wert-El-Wert-Balls.
Aber es gibt ja ein Internet.
Es gibt Internet. Genau, also Tim und ein paar andere Leute von uns sind gerade in Toronto und bauen dort irgendwie zur Nuit Blanche Blinkenlights auf. Und zwar diesmal auf zwei Häusern sogar. Also das ist immer ein bisschen besser als beim letzten Mal.
Die kurze Quereinstiegsgeschichte nebenbei. Was ist Blinkenlights?
Blinkenlights kamen das erste Mal vor fünf, sechs Jahren in Berlin. Haben im Haus des Lehrers hinter jedes Fenster, also wer das Haus des Lehrers kennt, am Alex, irgendwie dieses große, schöne alte DDR-Gebäude mit 144 Fenstern, haben hinter jedes Fenster einen Scheinwerfer gestellt, die ganzen Scheinwerfer verkabelt und irgendwie zum Rechner gebracht und haben praktisch jedes Fenster einzeln an- und ausschalten können. Also was man dann tun konnte, es hatten so kleine Kurzfilme abspielen, man konnte Pong drauf spielen, das heißt man konnte auch anrufen und halt dieses alte Computerspiel mit den zwei Balken, die sich links und rechts bewegen und den Ballländer mithin hüpft. Man konnte Liebesnachrichten übertragen.
Ach, wir sollten mal empfehlen, dass der geneigte Zuhörer bei der Suchmaschine seiner Wahl einfach mal blinken, Lights eintippt und dann wird er Filme finden und bei YouTube und...
Also es ist im Wesentlichen viel mehr als nur ein paar bunte blinkende Lampen, die irgendwelche Muster angeben.
Also es war auch sehr erfolgreich, die Toten Hosen zum Beispiel haben ein Video, irgendwie ein Musikvideo damit gedreht oder da drin und das gibt es jetzt wieder. Sie sind gerade beim Aufbau, soll fertig sein am 4. Oktober, aber sie sind halt inzwischen schon, also fast fertig, hat er mir gestern erzählt, das heißt irgendwie da kann man sich dann auf jeden Fall freuen, mal irgendwie Web Stream anklicken und dann mal ein bisschen zu gucken.
Blinken Lights.
Es ist Blinken Lights, also wie blinkende lichter.net und da findet man alles, was man schon immer wissen wollte.
Sehr schön. Kompliment an dieser Stelle immer wieder an Tim, die sich so abgefahrene Geschichten ausdenken.
Ja, wir sind irgendwie glaube ich im CCC alle Blinken Lights, das ist einfach schön.
Datengarten.
Ja, wir haben in Berlin wieder einen Datengarten, auf den wir verweisen wollen, wenn ihr aus Berlin und Umgebung kommt. Und zwar am 16. Oktober, also noch vor unserer nächsten Sendung hier bei Fritz. Und zwar im Berliner Club, im CCCB, in der Marienstrasse 11 in Mitte. Da kann man um 20 Uhr das Thema Weltraummedizinforschung hören. Wir haben Dr. Birgitta Ganser eingeladen und sie wird uns da auf den neuesten Stand bringen und einen Überblick über das Gebiet der Weltraummedizin bringen. Da sind wir schon ziemlich gespannt. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt überhaupt keine Ahnung über Weltraummedizinforschung, aber danach sind wir vielleicht alle schlauer.
Also Datengarten ist nichts für kleine Botaniker, sondern eine Vortragsreihe zu...
Na ja, Vortragsreihe würde ich es nicht nennen, ist eher so. Wenn wir interessante Themen haben, dann findet es statt. Und man kann gleichzeitig vielleicht auch mal den Berliner Chaos Computer Club kennenlernen.
Wir haben noch ein Thema total vergessen, und zwar das Wochenende vorher am 11. Oktober ist natürlich die große Freiheit hat Angst Demonstration.
Genau, weil ihr die Schnauze voll habt von den biometrischen Gesichtsbildern, von der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, von der Kennzeichnung. Jedenfalls ist die schöne Demo. Wir hoffen auf tolle Wetter und auf ganz viele Besucher am 11. Oktober.
Genau, also kommt einmal vorbei, sagt euren Freunden Bescheid, kommt irgendwie und zeigt dem Staat, dass ihr irgendwie mit seinen Maßnahmen nicht einverstanden seid.
Genau, so und zu allerletzt haben wir natürlich jetzt noch einen Hinweis, den wir am Anfang der Sendung schon mal gemacht haben. Wir möchten euch auffordern heraus zur Wahlbeobachtung, wenn am 28. September in Brandenburg gewählt wird. Und wer wissen will, welche Gemeinden, der klickt einfach mal auf ccc.de. Da ist auch eine Liste von den zehn Gemeinden. Und wer sich irgendwie motivieren kann, der soll sich an uns wenden, nämlich an wahlcomputer.de und in der Mail schreiben. Und zum Beispiel ein bestimmtes Wahllokal und Stadtansagen, wo er gerne beobachten möchte. Denn wir wollen versuchen, alle diese, jetzt sind glaube ich 283, Wahlcomputer zu beobachten, also eine vollständige Abdeckung von Brandenburg zu machen.
Wobei die Vergangenheit gezeigt hat, dass Wahlcomputer eine relativ unsichere Kiste sind.
Genau, wir werden vielleicht sogar mit der Piratenpartei da zusammenarbeiten. Also es gibt noch andere Organisationen, die da mit beobachten. Und wir hoffen, dass wir die Wahllokale alle abdecken können. Die Hacker kommen.
Okay, das war's. Wir drücken die Daumen. Euch eine gute Nacht. Danke fürs Zuhören. Für eure Beteiligung an dieser Sendung. Nochmal zu hören geht das Ganze unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Da gibt es auch die Vorschau für die Themen der nächsten Sendung. Wir sind dann Ende Oktober wieder da. Hier geht es jetzt weiter mit Smith & Smart im Night Flight. Und das letzte Stück des Abends kriegt Charles Hamilton, Produzent aus den Staaten, der einen sehr amüsanten Rap gebastelt hat aus dem Sound des Windows Media Player. In diesem Sinne, das war's Chaos Radio.
Bis denn.
Ciao.